SETH LADD: My name
is Seth Ladd.
And I want to welcome you to
another of our broadcasts
live, talking all about the
Dartiverse with Dartisans as
we eat dar-- taters.
Anyway, we have really awesome
special guests here today
talking lots of stuff.
It's been a little while,
so I want to catch up
everyone on the news.
We'll talk about the events in
the Dart world and meet more
community members.
So with that, let's go
to the Hangout and
I'll introduce everybody.
From the Seattle Dart team,
we have Dart engineers Bob
Nystrom and Nathan Weizenbaum.
Say hello, guys.
NATHAN WEIZENBAUM: Whatup.
BOB NYSTROM: Hey.
SETH LADD: Thanks
for joining us.
And also from Seattle, Kevin
Moore, a community member,
open source contributor,
and all around
great software engineer.
Hi, Kevin.
Thanks for joining us.
KEVIN MOORE: Good
to see you guys.
Nice to be here.
SETH LADD: So we got a lot
of stuff to cover.
So why don't we go ahead
and dive into it.
Let's go over some of the news
that we've been seeing.
And a special shout-out
to Chris Buckett over
there from the UK.
He's been doing a great job
every week or so collecting
the news for us.
And a couple items I
want to call out.
First, of course, last week, two
weeks ago, was Google I/O.
And all those videos
are now live.
So if you're interested
in catching up with--
let's see, we had Lars and
Kasper give a talk.
We had Dan and DJ give a talk.
We had Ray Cromwell
give a talk.
And then Jaime and
I had a Code Lab.
All the videos, the PDFs from
the Code Lab, are now all
posted on Google I/Os site.
So you got to definitely
check all those out.
I think it went really well,
a lot of good questions.
And I hope you can
watch those.
Let's also see what Chris
has collected for us
on his blog, Dartwatch.
We should probably point out
that Brandon Donaldson has
been doing a good job collecting
lots of different
examples of different bits and
parts of the Dart language.
And so if you're interested in
learning more about those,
c.dart-examples.com.
And we'll post all of the
links in the show notes.
But Brandon has been doing a
good job with lots and lots of
different examples there for you
to see what the language
looks like.
The DartFlash library,
which is--
its author, Bernhard Pichler,
is pitching as a safe haven
for ex-Flash developers
moving over to Dart,
has started a blog.
And he's got an open source game
written in Dart using his
DartFlash library.
So definitely check that out.
If you have any experience
with ActionScript 3, this
might be interesting to you.
John Evans continues his
work on Buckshot.
In fact, today he just released
a screenshot of his
new Tree control.
And John Evans is one of our
earliest adopters of Dart and
one of the authors of
a growing client
site, MVVM type framework.
So if you're interested in
building client-side web apps
with Dart, definitely
check out the work
John has been doing.
Let's talk about some of
the upcoming events.
And this is definitely where
Kevin and Bob can shed some
good color here.
This weekend is a hackathon
in Seattle--
actually, at the Google
offices in Freemont--
to learn and play
all about Dart.
Kevin, tell us a little bit
about what you expect to see
and happen at the Seattle
Dart Hackathon.
KEVIN MOORE: I'm happy to.
Oh, and it looks like
our video is finally
up, which is great.
Seth had coordinated a bunch
of hackathons around the
world, actually.
Was it in April,
mostly, or May?
SETH LADD: Yeah, something
like that.
KEVIN MOORE: And I realized
there was none in Seattle.
And I knew there were guys in
Seattle working on Dart.
And so I basically was just
the squeaky wheel and said
it'd be great to have an
event here in Seattle.
And so with some amazing
collaboration with Seth and
Bob and friends at the Fremont
office here in Seattle, we're
going to have a hackathon
on Saturday.
And so basically, this is an
opportunity for those that are
interested in Dart can play
around or want to learn can
get together, meet some people
that are actually on the Dart
team at Google, and have a
chance to write some software,
meet other people that are
interested in Dart, and
hopefully learn and
have a good time.
SETH LADD: And how
much is this free
hackathon this weekend?
KEVIN MOORE: The retail
price is $99.
But if you register
now, you'll get
in for free, I believe.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
KEVIN MOORE: We're going to
do bagels and doughnuts.
And we'll provide lunch and
some snacks and dinner.
So you'll be well fed.
And, of course, the
Wi-Fi is free.
SETH LADD: And when is this free
hackathon this weekend?
KEVIN MOORE: We're starting at
9:00 AM on Saturday in the
Freemont office.
For those that live in Seattle,
you'll know what the
neighborhood is.
And we have an event bright page
we'll send a link to for
people to register.
And this afternoon, hopefully
I'll send out an email to
people there with details
about where to show up.
And if you have ideas for
projects you'd like to work on
or like to see worked on, you
can register for those things.
So take a look at the show
notes once the video gets
published and you'll be able
to see details there.
And just make sure you register
so we know how many
to plan for.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
Yes, definitely register.
Bring your friends.
We have lots of space.
And it's going to
be a lot of fun.
And this is a good segway over
to talk to Bob because Bob is
going to grace us with his
introduction to Dart talk,
which is also going to
premiere at OSCON.
And so, Bob, talk to us a little
bit about your OSCON
event and what you hope to
talk about there in your
presentation.
BOB NYSTROM: You can't say that
it's going to premiere at
OSCON if I'm also doing it
at the Dart Hackathon.
It can't premiere
in both places.
SETH LADD: That is true.
BOB NYSTROM: So my OSCON talk
is basically not so much an
introduction to the
language itself.
It skims over the language.
But it's mostly a contextual
talk to just describe why we
thought it was a good idea to
make Dart, and a bit about at
the high level why it's designed
the way it is.
Hopefully, it will
be entertaining.
But I make no promises.
And then mostly for my own
personal benefit, I'll be
doing the same talk this
Saturday at the hackathon as a
dress rehearsal.
You know when '90s bands decide
to come back and do a
reunion tour, and before they do
the real tour, they do some
club dates?
This will be like my club date,
except that I'm not
actually a famous '90s band.
I'm just some guy.
SETH LADD: So this is the
intimate club setting before
you sell out as a big artist and
you play the arena shows.
BOB NYSTROM: Exactly, right.
SETH LADD: OK, awesome.
So remind us, when is OSCON
and where is it this year?
BOB NYSTROM: OSCON
is next week.
I think it goes from
Monday to Friday.
I don't know.
I'm only there from Wednesday
to Friday.
It's in Portland, Oregon.
I think it's always
in Portland.
And it's awesome.
There's a lot of big pile of
nerds all getting together
doing nerd stuff.
My talk is on Thursday.
If you're going to be at OSCON,
my talk is on Thursday
at 10:40 in the morning,
I think.
I should probably know this.
And it's going to be awesome.
And by awesome, I mean I might
do something embarrassing that
you could laugh at.
SETH LADD: And you have
some sort of Office
Hours, is that right?
BOB NYSTROM: I do.
I do, indeed.
So I signed up for Office Hours,
which I think basically
just means it's a time
and a place where you
can find me at OSCON.
So that Thursday afternoon, I
have some Office Hours and you
can go bug me.
Or if you just see me wandering
around, you can bug
me then too.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
And do you know if your
presentation at OSCON is going
to be video recorded at all?
BOB NYSTROM: I think it is
going to be recorded.
But I don't know if it's
going to be put online.
I don't know exactly what
the details are.
I know OSCON records
all the talks.
But I don't seem to see them
appear on YouTube.
I don't know if they--
SETH LADD: Yeah, I think you
have to buy in a package deal
or something.
We'll see if we can get a
recording for everyone at home
to follow along if you can't
be there at OSCON.
But, of course, if you're going
to be there, Bob's an
awesome guy.
He's really active on the
mailing list, really friendly.
And so certainly step up,
say hi, even if you
can't make his talk.
Let us know what you
think about Dart.
BOB NYSTROM: So what I'm
thinking I'll probably do is
I'll just record the talk
separately myself, just do a
screencast and put up
there, just so--
I've done all the work to
rehearse it, I might as well,
might as well get as much
mileage out of it as I can.
SETH LADD: Yeah, great.
KEVIN MOORE: That'll be
the studio recording.
BOB NYSTROM: That's right.
SETH LADD: That's right,
yes, highly produced.
BOB NYSTROM: I'll dub some crowd
sounds so it feels a
little more live and then
we'll go from there.
SETH LADD: And one other event
I have coming up, it's quite
in the future, though,
November 11 and 12.
If you're in the Bay Area, be
sure to stop by and check out
Learn Game Engine Development
with Dart and WebGL.
This is really cool.
John McCutcheon and Don Olmstead
are putting together
a two day class to teach you
all about game development
using WebGL and programming
everything in Dart.
And these are hard-core game
developers, familiar in C and
C++ and C#.
And I think it's really
encouraging, at least for me,
to see guys that would have
targeted machine code before
and find programming the browser
now really interesting
and exciting thanks to Dart.
And so that's in the
middle of November.
If you're around,
check that out.
Don gave a talk in San Francisco
a couple weeks ago
about using WebGL in Dart.
And I believe that
got recorded.
You can find that on Adam
Smith's Google+ feed.
So if you want a little teaser
there, check that out.
But it's cool to see more
developers, not just endemic
web developers, come to
Dart in the browser.
So keep that on the radar.
That's what I have for
news and events.
I think one of the big things
that we saw come out in the
past couple weeks was
Bob's article on
Dart language M1 changes.
What we're trying to do is get
ready for this concept of a
public beta, public SDK.
And to do that, of course, we
need to draw a line in the
sand, if you will,
around language
changes, and try to say--
excuse me-- this is the stuff
we're going to do soon.
This is the stuff
we'll do later.
This is the stuff we don't
think we'll do.
The stuff we're doing soon,
we're labeling as M1.
And I think we're getting really
close to what that
looks like.
And Bob took the time to write
up a really great article,
which is on dartlang.org.
If you go into Articles,
you can see
Milestone 1 Language Changes.
And I thought we could spend a
few minutes talking about some
of the more exciting ones that
Kevin, Nathan, and Bob might
have on their radar,
excites them, or
interests them the most.
We're not going to cover
everything in here.
But I don't know.
Kevin, have you seen some
of the recent language
changes come down?
KEVIN MOORE: Oh, wow, you
put me on the spot.
SETH LADD: I did.
You should have the entire
site memorized.
BOB NYSTROM: No pressure, man.
No pressure.
KEVIN MOORE: Oh, wow.
Actually, it's what's funny is
the things I'm most excited
about are things that are
tracked and owned, but have
yet to come in.
Nathan's work on the pub stuff
I'm super excited about.
Obviously, the big discussion--
and I was
involved with that as well-- is
the notion of an interface
is going away and it's all
going to be classes.
And that obviously was a big
argument and discussion.
I think it's been resolved
really well.
And obviously, the philosophy
that keeping the language as
simple as possible
but no simpler--
I think Einstein said something
around those lines--
is a good idea.
So that discussion has been
really healthy, I think.
And honestly, I think the most
important thing is just
watching how the community has
been involved with the Dart
team and the discussion
groups.
The team has been
very responsive.
Seth has been spectacular
about talking to people.
So it's been really fun to get
plugged in to the ground floor
in that respect.
And from my perspective looking
at what's coming
through, just seeing everything
tighten up and
decisions getting locked down
is exciting, so that we know
the more code you
write in Dart.
And I've written
a bunch so far.
Hopefully, that means less churn
later, which is always a
good thing.
SETH LADD: And I think
that's the idea.
If we lock down the language
a little bit now, the other
pieces can start building on
with more assumptions.
Bob or Nathan, what's some of
the stuff that you saw coming
down with these M1 changes that
you're looking forward to
or found really interesting?
NATHAN WEIZENBAUM:
Go on, Nathan.
NATHAN WEIZENBAUM: Let
me look through--
I'm also pretty excited about
the removal of explicit
interfaces.
I think it's a good sign that
we're moving towards cleaning
up some of the unnecessary
stuff that the
language has built up.
I think some of the new features
like method cascades
are a potentially really
interesting way of doing a
jQuery style way of writing code
that deals with a lot of
accessors in chaining and stuff
that without having to
declare a bunch of temporary
variables--
I don't know.
What do you think, Bob?
BOB NYSTROM: Oh, nice, nice.
You just passed that on to me.
So one of the things that I
think is going to be cool once
we have it and we can
start poking with it
is re-export support.
So one of the things that people
talk a lot about Dart
as a point of confusion is the
difference between the hash
import and hash source.
And even once people understand
it, there's a lot
of stuff they don't like
about hash source.
So one of the things that I'm
interested in playing with is
trying to just not
use it at all.
So if you look at the pub code
base right now, it's not using
hash source.
It just uses hash import.
And it basically treats every
file as its own library.
And I think, in general,
I think that's a
better model for Dart.
I enjoy using Dart
more that way.
But there's a couple of things
that you can't do if you write
all your code like that.
And one of those is pulling
something from another file,
but then have it appear
to be coming from you.
And re-export is going
to plug that hole.
So I'm hoping that once that's
out and we can start playing
with it that that'll get us a
step towards just not having
to use source at all and maybe
keeping it in the language,
but getting rid of it in terms
of a feature that you use in
Idiomatic Dart code.
Because I think that makes Dart
simpler to reason about
where you can just say, oh, you
just compose stuff using
hash import.
But we'll have to do some
experimentation to see how
well that actually works and
if there's these weird
consequences that we aren't
thinking about.
But I think that has the
potential to make just
Idiomatic Dart a little easier
to work with and reason about.
So that's cool.
SETH LADD: Brandon from the
moderator asks, can you
guesstimate on the M1
aim for completion?
And I don't think we ever really
have a good idea when
that's going to happen.
I think this is on the sooner
side than later side, though.
I think we want to get M1 ironed
out so the other pieces
can be built.
But I don't think we have an
actual time frame for this.
BOB NYSTROM: Language design
is surprisingly hard.
If for kicks you decide to make
your hobby programming
language, it's an interesting
learning process.
And one of the things that's
tricky about it is you can't
tell if a design decision is
good until you've implemented
it and a decent amount
of code that uses it.
So your iteration loop for
cranking on the language is
pretty slow.
And it makes it hard to
be like, oh, yeah,
here's all the features.
They're going to be great.
And then they're done and then
the language is done.
SETH LADD: There's another
question on the moderator here
that asks about mixins.
Can you shed some light
on what mixins might
look like in Dart?
And I thought we could address
this now, what we're talking
about, some of the upcoming
language changes.
Have we heard anything
about mixins from
where you guys sit?
BOB NYSTROM: I've heard
bits and pieces.
I don't know exactly what
the status is or--
[INAUDIBLE].
I don't think the syntax
been nailed down yet.
My understanding is that the
basic idea should be pretty
close to what you assume, if
you're familiar with the
concept of mixins,
in that you can--
my understanding is basically
you can define a class that
takes another class and
effectively copies and pastes
those methods into your class.
So it gives you some of the
multi-way composition that
multiple inheritance gives you
without the crazy dispatch
shenanigans that
C++ gives you.
KEVIN MOORE: It doesn't modify
that class hierarchy, correct?
BOB NYSTROM: It's a complicated
question.
I think the effect of semantics
that you will see is
that, no, it doesn't.
But I think the way the
semantics end up being
described in the spec may make
it appear that they are.
The spec describes things in
an idealized, abstract
semantics way.
And in that description, I think
mixins will look like
they are more persistent in the
class hierarchy, whereas
in practice I think it will more
or less feel like those
methods just get slurped in.
And everything feels like
it's been flattened out.
But all of this is still up
in the air, so don't hold
me to any of it.
SETH LADD: Yeah, I believe it
came up at I/O. And it's
definitely on the road map.
And so I know we're trying
to get M1 out the door.
So I think we'll see this
sooner than later.
And I know there's a lot of
people asking for mixin.
So I think this is a highly
anticipated feature.
BOB NYSTROM: One of the things
that I'm excited about is that
because we're getting rid of
interfaces, if you look at the
core library right now, it looks
like it was designed,
especially the collections, by
people that were thinking Java
even though they were
writing Dart.
Everything is an interface
and there's this
hidden concrete class.
And because we're getting rid of
interfaces, I think we have
a chance to simplify
a lot of that.
So my hope is that a lot of
those things will just be
classes, and that by default,
you'll just being able to
sub-class them.
So it's possible that even
before mixins or in the
language that you'll be able
to do a little more code
re-use than you can do
with Dart right now.
Right now, if you want to re-use
some of the existing
code that implements
collections, it's really,
really nasty and hairy.
You have to go into
core [INAUDIBLE].
And there's platform
differences
and stuff like that.
So I'm hoping that by getting
rid of explicit interfaces,
even some of that stuff
will get surfaced
a little more easily.
SETH LADD: If you're interested
in what else is
coming down the pipe for the new
Dart M1 changes, go on to
dartlang.org and look for
Milestone 1 Language Changes
from the Articles section, or
just search for M1 Dart
Language Changes.
I think you'll find it.
There's a lot more in there that
we didn't cover, and some
really interesting
things in there,
like an as_cast operator.
I'll leave you with that
little teaser.
So certainly do catch up on
what's happening in the Dart
language world.
But we also care a lot
about the developer
experience in Dart.
Dart's a lot more than
just a language.
It's a whole batteries
included project.
And one of the--
BOB NYSTROM: Way of life.
SETH LADD: It's a
way of thinking.
One of the other anticipated
features that I really think
is going to blow open the
doors for third-party
developers is our pub package
management system.
And that's a great topic here
for our guests Bob and Nathan
and then Kevin.
So Bob and Nathan, you guys
are working on pub.
And Kevin, you've put forth a
proposal standard for what
these packages might
actually look like.
So let's dive into--
BOB NYSTROM: Which is
awesome, by the way.
SETH LADD: Yeah, good job.
KEVIN MOORE: Thank you.
SETH LADD: Let's get started
a little bit.
Bob and Nathan, can you spend
just a minute talking about
what pub is?
What is this going to mean
to the Dart developer?
NATHAN WEIZENBAUM: Pub
is a package manager.
So fundamentally, it's a
way of declaring which
dependencies your library or
application uses, and fetching
those dependencies from an
external source, and
installing them so that they're
available locally.
BOB NYSTROM: And dealing
with versions.
NATHAN WEIZENBAUM: It handles
version constraints so you can
say, I rely on version greater
than or equal to 1.0 of this
package and less than or equal
to 2.5 of this other package.
And it'll traverse the whole
dependency tree of everything
that those packages depend on,
and just figure out a whole
constellation of packages at
specific versions that will
work for your app.
It'll be able to update
packages to the latest
versions when you
want to do that.
So right now, it can install
packages from git repositories
and from the Dart SDK.
We are working on getting
a package repository on
dartlang.org up and running that
will eventually have a
way for Dart developers out in
the wild to create packages,
upload them there, and make them
available for other Dart
developers to use.
And it's pretty exciting.
It's an important step on the
road to an ecosystem of
libraries available for Dart
developers to use.
SETH LADD: One of the first
packages that I think we'll
see is Kevin's Dart lib.
And maybe that will conform to
his proposed standard for what
a package looks like.
So I find it interesting that
pub is about pulling a package
down and making it available
to your programs so you can
easily import it.
But it doesn't really speak too
much about what's inside
the package.
And I think that's where
Kevin comes in.
So Kevin, can you give us an
idea of what your idea of what
a package looks like?
What are some of the
assets in there?
How do they relate?
And what would you
like to see?
KEVIN MOORE: Absolutely.
I've spent time in a lot of
different worlds, obviously in
the .NET world, and they have
their NuGet solution, which
has come on in the last--
oh, lord-- year now, and has
made a lot of inroads.
And obviously, anyone who's done
node, is familiar with
MPM-- and RubyGems been around
for a long time.
And actually, one of the
first things I said was
please make pub more--
not only do what RubyGems does,
but do more what bundler
does-- again, for those
that are familiar
with the Ruby world--
because bundler goes to the next
step in making sure that
you understand what
you install,
you understand versions.
And it's a really powerful
solution.
So I was super excited to see
that we were just discussing
before we went live here that
I think for a lot of people,
this notion of package
management, dependency
management, is now in the top
list, along with you better to
have a collection class and
a model for events.
Yes, that is a shameless dig.
BOB NYSTROM: We need to get all
the right people in the
right room for that.
KEVIN MOORE: Exactly.
The pub spec talked a lot about
how do you get source
down and define your
dependencies, which is great.
But one of the nice things that
are bad things in the
Ruby world, at least--
and this probably applies to
other things-- is there's many
ways to lay out your directory
and your assets within a
package or within a gem
or whatever else.
And having a decent convention
around that is really helpful.
So an example would be if
I had to find a GitHub
repository for a package.
As someone that browses in
GitHub, I want to see samples
for that library.
I want to see tests
I want to see I for that
library, all these things.
But I think that dependency on
that library in terms of the
code I access, it's nice that
there's an explicit notion of
the code I'm importing is
everything in the lib
directory and only in
the lib directory.
And so having those things be
laid out and at least having a
convention around it
is super useful.
And so I created a package
called Dart blank lib, which
plays off the Dart lib
library I made, which
actually has content.
And Dart blank lib
is a few things.
One, it's a straw man of
how I think a package
could be laid out.
And once pub moves further in
the pub spec, file format
moves forward, that'll get
updated to match that.
And it's also I think really
useful for anyone that just
wants to start with a library.
It starts with a silly, simple,
stupid [? live ?] lib.
I think it just adds two
numbers together.
It has a little sample app.
It actually has a unittest that
verifies that I can add
two numbers together, again,
really difficult.
The idea is instead of just
forking this, you download it,
extract it, rename
things as you go.
But then things are
laid out in a
reasonable set of defaults.
Again, this is not
agreed upon.
But it lends nicely with what we
have in the RubyGems world
and the NuGet world and the MPM
world, and Python world
for that matter.
So I think it's a good place
for people to start.
And hopefully, its pub
spec and other
things evolve forward.
That will evolve as well
and tighten up.
And I'm always happy
to get feedback.
SETH LADD: And did you mention
this is on GitHub, that you
can find it how?
KEVIN MOORE: Yep.
We'll post a link.
It's under Kevmoo, is
my account GitHub.
And so a bunch of my [INAUDIBLE]
is there.
And that's one of them.
SETH LADD: Speaking of Dart fun,
you mentioned Dart lib,
that you extracted this
Dart blank lib from.
What is Dart lib?
KEVIN MOORE: I spent a few
years at Microsoft, about
three, working on their
frameworks, working on some of
their GUI frameworks.
And so I really got into this
framework state of mind around
how do you think about
factoring out
code, making it reusable?
And in the .NET world, I ran
forward and did something
called the bag of tricks, which
a lot of people played
with, related to Silverlight
and [INAUDIBLE]
and other .NET things.
When I started doing JavaScript
work, I made a
closure library, closure
compiler library, related to a
bunch of work that my company
did, Pixel Lab.
And so I wanted to play that
forward into Dart.
And so Dart lib is basically a
collection of stuff, most of
which I think is pretty
reasonable to say this is
relatively common.
And so by doing a bunch
of work on--
I'm calling it innumerable to
map to the .NET model so that
you can do chained .where,
.from, .select, .average, some
of the things you're used to
with links index and .NET,
along with some other
collection helpers.
I have a whole retained graphics
model that plays on
top of canvas that has hit
testing and some other things
I'm playing with.
So basically, I'm working on my
own little project for fun.
It's an idea I've had for almost
10 years now about
simulating and playing with
different election methods,
voting methods.
[INAUDIBLE]
moderator works.
And so as I'm running with that
vote.dart project, I call
it, I'm adding things
to Dart lib.
And the idea is if people want
size and repped, if they want
an event model, a disposable
model, it's always good to
share these concepts and not
be reinventing the wheel.
So I'm using it for
my projects.
I've already taken a few patches
from some other folks.
And I'm happy to collaborate
with others.
Please forks and
hold requests.
I'm excited to expand out some
of these base libraries.
And certainly what makes the
.NET world awesome and MPM and
RubyGems, there always seems
to be this handful of
libraries that everyone uses.
And it makes just--
even with the sink included.
And so this adds some nice
chrome to the sink and a
shower and a stove.
And hopefully it will make using
Dart more fun and more
productive for a
lot of people.
SETH LADD: I think it not only
reduces the amount of work you
have to do to get started with
the project, but it's really
nice to have these common bits
of functionality across Dart
projects so that a Dart
developer can approach
multiple different projects
and feel more
comfortable more quickly.
So I think there's a lot there
when you have that convention
over configuration, or just
simply the shared convention
of what the common
libraries are.
So definitely, thank
you for that.
And it's really cool to see
that you're already taking
patches for that.
The question I love to ask our
external community members is
what is some of the things you'd
like to see from the
Dart project?
You've written a lot of code.
I'm sure you have
a couple ideas.
KEVIN MOORE: What would I like
to see from the Dart project?
I actually started writing
a list of these things.
There's some outstanding bugs
around field instantiate,
final static variables with
const, and this weirdness
there that's causing some issues
in my own library.
I'd love to see--
go ahead.
BOB NYSTROM: Is it that you want
non-const final statics?
KEVIN MOORE: Both, actually.
Const final statics
don't work yet.
There's bugs on it that I'm
tracking, and just waiting for
those to be resolved.
If anyone loads up
the Dart lib--
and actually, you get errors
in the Dart editor.
Thankfully, it [INAUDIBLE]
everything works.
But you'll see all kinds
of errors come up.
Other things that've been
discussed are being able to do
[? key ?] statements against
classes, so emulate what an
[? enum ?] is.
I think those issues are
being tracked there.
BOB NYSTROM: That actually does
work now and is going to
stop working.
KEVIN MOORE: I get warnings
on it now.
So you're saying it's
actually going to
completely stop working?
BOB NYSTROM: So right now in
Dart, you can do the Java type
safety [? node ?]
pattern where you have an
[? enum ?] like class that has
static instances of itself.
And then you can switch
on those.
And the changes we're making to
switch to constrain it will
I think at least until it's
been specified right now
nullify that pattern,
unfortunately.
But I know they're talking about
loosing it up a bit to
basically keep that working.
KEVIN MOORE: So I pre-file
my bug now?
We joke around about
that stuff.
Obviously, I think the Dart team
is doing a good job to
keep the first release tight.
BOB NYSTROM: [INAUDIBLE].
KEVIN MOORE: Go ahead.
[? BOB NYSTROM: Enums ?]
are a valid concern.
And at least we had a
pattern for a while.
So I think it's a gap that we
know we want to fill somehow.
And I just don't know if we've
really filled it yet.
KEVIN MOORE: I'll take no
solution in the short term
better than a broken
solution that we
have to support forever.
So that's awesome.
Oh, and really quickly, we
talked about an event model
which people discussed.
I have an implementation
that basically maps
to the closure library.
It actually allows my code to
just map to what the closure
[INAUDIBLE] have done.
So having that formalized, I
think that's something that
would be actually good to have
in the core framework.
And then these other things
that've been discussed a lot,
I'd love to have generic
methods.
That's something that's brought
up by a few people.
And so those aren't super
needed for B1.
Obviously, that's something
that can be added later.
And then related to the mixins
thing, I'd much rather have
extension methods, which is a
model that is exists in C#.
But obviously, for a lot of
these things, a lot of people
just want their pet feature from
their favorite language.
And if it doesn't gel, we'll
always be mad, but we have to
stick to the spirit
of the language.
So I'm not expecting 100%
alignment with everything I
love about .NET.
Because at the same time, I can
run it in a browser, which
I can't do with C#.
So I'll take the good
with the bad.
SETH LADD: Good list.
Thanks.
And it sounds like you're
already plugged in to the
issue tracker.
And that's the best way.
And so if you, watching this at
home, have ideas, certainly
join the mailing list,
dartlang.org/mailing-list, or
you can file issues and
bugs at dartbug.com.
So lots of good ways to
get a hold of us.
It's an all and open
source project.
And we have lots of engineers
active on the mailing list and
answering the issues.
So we'd love to hear what you
have on your short list of
things you want to see
for the project.
We should probably also mention,
before we move into
the Q&A section here, is that
pubs in the SDK today-- and as
Nathan mentioned, you can
install stuff from git now.
So you have the bases of
pub are there working.
Kevin's start lib is there,
working on GitHub.
You can pull that down
and play with that.
So a lot of the stuff we're
talking about today is
operational in some form and
coming online very quickly.
And so it's definitely a good
place for you guys to play,
experiment, try your libraries,
and then give us
that feedback as we roll into
this M1 phase of the project.
BOB NYSTROM: I will throw out
the caveat, though, that
you're certainly welcome
to start poking at
pub, but it's at 0.0.0.
We're still in active
development.
So we reserve the right to break
everything, set your
computer on fire.
KEVIN MOORE: Don't close
[? the bet. ?]
BOB NYSTROM: You're certainly
welcome to try it out.
But you're taking your life into
your own hands if you do.
Hopefully, it won't set
your computer on fire.
SETH LADD: Right.
Yeah, I don't think we have
that bit enabled.
But the flip side of that is
it's a good opportunity to try
it out and let us know what
are the use cases that you
need to get solved.
Because now we can take the
opportunity to break stuff to
make sure we hit those
major use cases.
So I think that's, to me, what
keeps this project really
exciting right now is
that, yes, things
are moving very quickly.
But you're part of something
new, something that's going to
be big, right at the
early stages.
And that's really exciting, to
see it be born and grow, and
maybe even help influence
its design.
So we've got a couple questions
from the moderator
for you guys.
Let's see if we can answer
some of these.
These are all voted up
from the community.
We've already answered
some of them.
But this one comes up a lot,
is the Dart widget control
[INAUDIBLE]
library on the roadmap based
on closure library
or a port of it?
And do we have any
sort of timing?
I know that the Seattle
team's working on
some sort of UI library.
You guys are there in Seattle.
Have you see anything happen
there, or what's going on?
BOB NYSTROM: I definitely
see stuff happening.
There are people
working on it.
As far as whether it's based on
closure, it's maybe heavily
inspired by closures is
a good description.
It's not a straight port.
And I don't think there's an
intention for it to be a
straight port.
But I think closure is probably
the widget framework
that is the closest mental model
at hand when they're
designing that stuff.
As far as roadmap and timeframe,
there's the usual
we don't usually make
predictions stuff.
We'd like it really soon because
we know people totally
want it really bad.
And we'd like it to
be out there.
But I don't know what
the timing is.
SETH LADD: And I think, again,
it helps when the language
settles down a little bit,
and then the library.
So these things build
on each other.
And just to me, at the top,
really, is that UI library.
So a lot of stuff I think has
to happen before that lands.
But there are a bunch of open
source projects out there that
are trying to build a
MVVM framework too.
So it doesn't have to come
from the Dart project
necessarily for you guys
to get started.
We mentioned John Evans
with Buckshot.
Another one we just saw came out
yesterday on git release--
we just found on GitHub
yesterday--
I think it's Dart MVVM.
There's a port of pure MVC.
I'm sure there's others.
Chris Buckett has a good list
of community projects.
So in other words, there are
options out there if you guys
are interested.
And Kevin with his Dart lib is
taking cues and inspiration
from closure as well.
And so I think there's a lot to
get started with, for sure.
Let's see.
Neo from New York City writes,
is Google eating its own dog
food by using Dart internally
on Google projects?
So while we won't comment on any
internal projects, we can
say there are internal teams
checking out Dart and giving
us good feedback.
The tricky part there is that,
as you can probably imagine,
the Google infrastructure has
a unique set of constraints.
And so we try to balance
building Dart for our open
source developers, the external
developers, who we
really see as our primary
audience, but also try to
balance that with our internal
customer needs.
And so we play this tricky
balancing game.
But there are internal
teams looking at it.
But I think we're squarely
interested in making this and
keeping this an open source
project for all developers out
there to use.
And that's one of the things
that excites me at least about
Dart because it's not just
for Google by Google.
This is really to help all
developers, not just even
endemic web developers,
to build awesome
stuff for the web.
John Evans writes, how is pub
for Windows coming along?
Guys, guys?
BOB NYSTROM: Every day or two,
Nathan and I poke each other
and say, not it.
The actual quantity of work that
we need to do for Windows
support is pretty small.
There's a couple of places in
the code base that don't work.
And we have to fix those.
So basically when it's shelling
out to a couple of
things, we need to do some
Windows specific stuff there.
And we will do that
relatively soon.
I'm not sure what the
timeframe is.
But probably the best way to
describe this is we don't
officially support any operating
system with pub.
It's still under development.
SETH LADD: How convenient.
BOB NYSTROM: But definitely,
I can say for me, I'm very
cognizant that the longer we
delay working on Windows, the
more technical debt
we're accruing.
And I don't want to be
deep in that hole.
So right now, I don't have
a lot of time to
be working on pub.
But as soon as I can get back to
it, it's really high on my
list of stuff that
I want to do.
Because I think it's very
important for pub to be a good
citizen and to work equally
well across
all operating systems.
NATHAN WEIZENBAUM: I don't think
we'll consider it done
until it supports Windows.
BOB NYSTROM: Definitely not.
SETH LADD: I like
that mentality.
And it's not an excuse or cop
out or anything, but I do want
to say, of course, that
Dart is open source.
And I believe the pub tool-- is
the pub tool in a separate
repository?
What is that?
BOB NYSTROM: So pub is
in the main repo.
And it has to be in
the main repo.
If you imagine farther down the
future when Pub is closer
to done, what you would
do is you would
install the Dart SDK.
SDK.
And all that really needs to
include is a Dart VM and pub
so that then you can
get all the other
packages through pub.
But pub does have to be there.
It's part of your batteries
included bootstrap process.
So Pub is in the main repo.
But the hosting site, the
package hosting site we're
working on, that Nathan's
working on, pub.dartlang.org,
that's in a separate
repository.
SETH LADD: That's what
I thought, OK.
We take patches.
I believe we've taken even a
patch from John and others.
And so step on up, I guess.
We'll definitely get to it.
But it is open source.
And we've taken patches.
So that's cool.
Lattice Lava, a guy really
active on the mailing list,
writes, Dart's library system
is known to be changed
sometime in the future.
Are there any details
on that already?
And will it allow creating a
package management system
completely independent of the
language without the need to
specify the package: scheme?
Yeah, go ahead and see
if you can get that.
NATHAN WEIZENBAUM: I think
package colon is going to be
around for at least a while,
partially because of the
constraints of supporting both
browser development and server
side development.
For the browser, it's very
important that the actual
files that you use as your
libraries are available in a
place that the web server can
see them and then serve them
to the browser.
And the package directory
solution does a good job of
managing that.
I think we have some hopes that
the syntax for it will
evolve into something more
palatable, possibly even
something that doesn't require
you to write package colon.
But I think the fundamental
import structure will be
pretty similar for the
foreseeable future.
BOB NYSTROM: So the high level
goal that Lattice Lava is
talking about is will Dart the
language support multiple
independent package managers?
And that was definitely a design
constraint when Kasper
was coming up with the
package colon stuff.
So the idea is we basically
need to have this minimum
interface, this minimum level of
abstraction, that all Dart
implementations support, and
that that gives you just
enough of a port to
jam in your own
package management system.
And the package colon prefix,
as syntactically ugly as it
is, is basically that port.
So the idea is every Dart
implementation is hard coded
to know what to do with a
package colon import.
But all that does is swizzles
your URL to something.
And you can implement your
own package manager.
And as long as it generates
something that ends up at that
swizzled URL, you can have
whatever incoming semantics
you want for that.
So that's the idea.
It still doesn't feel
totally baked yet.
And definitely, I would
certainly like the
syntax to be better.
And it's something that
I'm hoping we can
turn the crank on.
But there's never any timeframe
or anything.
NATHAN WEIZENBAUM: I've
actually got to run.
Goodbye, everyone.
SETH LADD: All right.
Thank you Nathan.
And I think with that, we've
ran up most of the good
questions on there.
And I want to take again this
opportunity to thank all our
special guests: Nathan,
Bob, Kevin.
Thank you guys so much.
Best of luck with pub, your talk
at OSCON, the hackathon
this Saturday.
I'll see you guys there,
and anyone else that's
going to be there too.
And just a lot of good stuff
happening around Dart.
And so to follow along, of
course, we have the Dart
mailing list, misc@dartlang.org.
We have the issue tracker,
dartbug.com.
Of course, the Google+ page,
+Dart, and the hashtag, which
I see being used on Twitter
and Google+, #dartlang.
So lots of ways to
follow along.
And we'll do more of these.
And so we hope to see you
next time at another
broadcast of Dartisans.
And we hope to see you
in the mailing list.
And thank you for trying Dart.
So thanks, guys, and we'll
see you next time.
KEVIN MOORE: Take care.
SETH LADD: Aloha.